in this video we'll be talking about
listeria monocytogenes infection
listeria monocytogenes is a bacterial
pathogen that is responsible for causing
the infection known as listeriosis
it is commonly found in soil water and
in some animals
listeriosis primarily affects pregnant
women and the newborn can also get the
infection from mother during the time of
birth
listeria monocytogenes get transmitted
via several mechanism first of all via
contaminated food via unpasteurized
dairy products or from raw meat
especially the pregnant women are at
higher risk of infection while listeria
monocytogenes and that is not very
pleasant thing during the pregnancy it
can lead to several problems in the
fetus
let's talk about the microbiology of
listeria monocytogens these are slender
short gram positive rods they do not
form spores like many gram-positive
bacteria and sometimes they occur in
Diplo basily format or in short chains
they are Avid intracellular parasites
anyway as they are gram-positive in a
slide they would stain dark purple if we
talk about the lab diagnosis of listeria
monocytogenes the first bus analysis is
crumb staining they should stain dark
purple and one can see the clear Rod
like structures and then they would
produce small Colony with a narrow zone
of beta hemolysis in a blood agar plate
also there would be Catalyst positive
now let's talk about the pathology of
listeria bonus cytogenes infection so
generally when listeria invades the body
the macrophages try to engulf them but
listeria has specific mechanism to evade
the macrophage mediated immunity first
of all when the listeria is engulfed in
the macro fetch they would create the
phagol lysosome but eventually the
phagol lysosome would be lysed with the
help of listeriolysin o
then the bacteria forms a tale of actin
cytoskeleton using the cellular actin
cytoskeleton of the macrophage and that
helps them to propel inside the
macrophage and eventually evade from the
macrophage and then they can infect
another macrophage or circulate in the
bloodstream as well
let's talk about the risk of
monocytogenes infection so generally
listeria monocytogen infection comes
from hygiene issues while preparing the
food or consuming Street Food
so in many cases washing hands and
cross-contamination is a big issue so
overall hygiene has to be good in in
terms of
preventing the infection
now pregnant women are at higher risk so
they should really be careful about
consuming specific vegetables or
specific uh dairy products they has to
ensure that they are pasteurized because
non-pasteurized dairy product might be
contaminated with many bacteria
now let's talk about the treatment of
the listeria infection as it's a
bacteria it can be treated with
antibiotics antibiotics like ampicillin
could be a choice for treatment other
than that
trimethoprim and sulfur methoxazole
could be also another option
so prompt diagnosis would ensure that
the quick cure of this particular
disease if it's a pregnant woman again
the complications could be long lasting
now if listeriences occur during
pregnancy it might even affect the fetus
even after birth so that is why the
pregnant woman should be very careful
about this kind of infection
so this is a quick summary about
listeria monocytogenous infection if you
like our video give it a quick thumbs up
you can get more flash cards and notes
in my Facebook page support us using
patreon or super tanks it's a icon which
is present in the bottom right corner of
your video
you can find more notes and flashcards
in our Instagram page visit it and see
you in next video